through most of the last challenging
year
marco zarfatti has kept his family run
tie shop open
now he says it wasn't worth it something
like a tragedy i don't want to be
catastrophic but i have uh
tens and tens uh
[Music]
thousands of euros
debt with the bank with my parents
who helped me rome is a city that is
heavily dependent on tourism
and so as the world stopped travelling
due to the coronavirus
the once bustling and vibrant italian
capital has ground to a halt
to have these world famous sites almost
all to yourself would have been
unthinkable simply plain and possible a
year ago and even though it may be a
privilege to see the trevi fountain
without the usual hordes of taurus this
unprecedented emptiness tells the story
of just how desperate
the economic situation here has become
a vaccination campaign is underway and
the government says at least one million
people have already been inoculated
it's giving some hope but most people
say they know it's not a quick fix
italy is one of the worst of countries
on both
counts the number of death and
the economic impact what we do know is
that the economic effect of all this is
going to be
very tough and that italy is going to
get out of this
with uh almost unmanageable public debt
that's a certainty
what isn't uncertain is this country's
political future giuseppe conte the
prime minister
is facing two votes of confidence early
this week after one of his coalition
parties pulled its ministers out of his
cabinet
it could lead to a political crisis at a
time when the country needs at least
lockdown measures have recently been
extended meaning restaurants and bars
need to remain
shut and a nighttime curfew extended for
at least another month
italy is defined by a food and wine
culture and restaurant owners are
desperate
i i feel like to 11 months ago
so nothing has changed you're saying in
11 months nothing
nothing sometimes i feel like a stupid
because i say that i spend 20 years
here why why i spend
20 years here is it possible
one virus stop my life
like so many other italians robert is
left worried about mounting debts
continued restrictions and no idea when
it will all end
stephanie decker al jazeera rome